[Music]
welcome back everybody to the second
part of the key candid moments series
here at the halfway point of the
candidates tournament and we're going to
continue with the remainder for players
that we haven't analyzed as of now and
I'm going to start with one of the
co-leaders of the event young upon Nia
she in this position I think this was
one of the most important moments in
this tournament for him because I think
it gave him the confidence that he can
simply outplay most of these guys from
quite equal positions and this was a
petrov and wong hau simplified the
position quite nicely of course he still
has a little bit of space advantage
white berries but not much more than
that and if you advance too much on the
kingside then potentially your king
could become weak and you could be in
danger and black has only one idea in
this position he wants to get his king
closer to the center as soon as possible
if he manages to do that his position is
going to be beautiful and nappa moyashi
with the white pieces understands that
and take takes the necessary risks to
create complications and try to pose
some problems for black he could easily
just play the move King to g2 slowly
slowly push his pieces a little bit
forward but unfortunately that wouldn't
be enough he understands that and he
immediately takes action and I think
this is one of his trademarks he's not
afraid to take action he's not afraid to
change the character of the position
change the structures of the position
and this has been giving him the edge in
most of his games this tournament in
this position he played the move h6
immediately trying to box the King on h8
of course if you take on h6 then I'm
just simply going to take back and
you're going to have some serious
problems because the pawn on f6 is going
to be a weakness I'm also threatening to
invade with a queen via f8
slowlyslowly I'm going to be able to
create unnecessary problems for black so
of course after age six the natural move
was g6 once again the same plan applies
for black I'm still trying to get the
King to have seven I still do not have
any weaknesses and actually from a
structural point of view it is white who
needs to pay a little bit of attention
because if you exchange the Queen's for
example imagine just the Queen's off the
board at this point I'm just simply
going to go Knight 12 seven and the pawn
on age six is actually going to be lost
also if I get the King to have seven
then I could potentially have ideas of
g5 put the King to g6 if the Queen's are
no longer on the board and again the
pawn on h6 is could become a liability
for white Shirley Nepal Miyagi
understood that and he understood that
he needs to continue with a very active
plan and he played the move C for a very
nice practical move which simply threw
one how off his rhythm because after he
takes e4 B takes e4 he had to take a
step back kind of shift his mind from
his idea his preconceived idea that he
needs to get his king at all costs in
the center and just realized that he
actually needs to play the move Knight
to f7 a very important move to keep the
attack on the pawn on h6 and the Queen
is going to be stuck to the defense of
the point on h6 of course I'm going to
be able to play the move d5 potentially
still I'm going to be able to improve
slowly slowly in my position but it
doesn't seem like there's a clear way
for white to make any sort of progress
instead of that he didn't play the move
Knight to have seven which was critical
he played the move King to g8
objectively the position is still very
very close to equality unfortunately
from a practical point of view white is
starting to get a lot of attacking ideas
and that's sometimes all you need you
play the move Queen to h2 threatening to
go to b8 and actually it's pretty much
impossible
to stop white from going to be eight you
don't have the move Queen to e8 because
the night is going to fall play them off
King to f7 c5 Knight to b5 Queen to b8
Queen to d7 which was a huge mistake and
this is what happens when you start
posing problems to your opponent in this
position Knight takes d4 was the right
move and after Queen to b7
you still have the move Queen to e7
you're going to take this point I'm
going to take the pawn on c5 and the
position is most likely going to be very
close to equality nevertheless from an
optical perspective after Queen to e7
and the exchange of the pawn on e6 with
the pawn on c5 I'm the one with a far
away past pawn on the a file you're the
one with quite a weak King because any
checks that are not met with the Queen
on the seventh rank are going to allow
me to potentially capture the pawn on h7
get the Queen on the Kings side behind
the pawns I have a lot of options and
optically just simply no longer looks
very good for for black of course with
an engine in front of us we can say that
oh yeah this is just this is just an
easy drop but from a practical
perspective is far from that and even a
2750 2760 player like Wang Hao was
unable to paint the position he played a
move Queen to d7 and after Queen 288 the
position is just simply winning for
white I think this definitely gave a
huge boost of confidence to Nepal
Miyoshi and this is why I believe this
is the key moment for him so far in this
tournament next one I want to talk about
is one how and what is his key moment in
the tournament and that I believe was a
clash with unhitch Giri he could have
won this is round two he could have went
to a no at this point and and that would
have been a huge result for him and
probably would have propelled him into
the lead and who knows maybe he wouldn't
have let it go but he seems to have
problems in the end games it seems like
he's just unable to
to find the killing blow in the end
games he guessed the advantage
beautifully builds a very nice reticle
advantage he gets the pawn he's a pawn
up he has Bishop against Knight there's
another weakness on d5 and now at this
point he just chooses the wrong plan he
played the move Bishop to d3 Knight to
c8 efore why would you exchange one of
my weaknesses why would you simplify the
position and then I'm simply going to be
able as black as we have seen in in the
remainder of the game I'm going to be
able to construct a defense based on the
dark squares and weight put their work
on v6 knight on d6 slowly-slowly kiri
went out of the bind and secured the
draw instead of that I think a much
better plan would have been to keep this
night tied to the defense of the pawn on
d5 put this rook on the C file once
again you cannot I'm controlling the
night you cannot move the knight because
I'm just going to invade wither look
look to see to them slowly rook to d4
and then I need to find a way to create
another weakness and that is going to be
via g4 I'm going to play at the right
moment g4 if you take on g4 I'm going to
take back then I'm going to be able to
create a passer that's going to be
another weapon that black needs to worry
about if you don't take on g4 after g4
I'm just simply going to be able to
exchange myself on h5 you're going to
take and then the bishop on e2 is going
to have another potential target on h5
is going to be a very very versatile
piece the bishop on it too right now is
defending the pawn on b5 very difficult
to attack the pawn on b5 of course you
don't want to give an exchange for it
and the knight once again is stuck to
the defense of d5 misunderstanding there
he just didn't understand that he why
would he exchange the pawn on d5 and I
think this is a mistake he shouldn't
make because he's such a good technical
player and he plays amazing chess it
seems like in these critical moments and
we've seen that in his game against the
maximum
Shelagh Grove as well he was a pawn up
once again in the endgame and he wasn't
able to to materialize his advantage
which is unexpected from a player of his
caliber so I think this game pretty much
was critical for his tournament in round
two
another player that I want to talk about
is Chris Cook who is always in time
trouble it seems he has been complaining
that he just simply cannot concentrate
he doesn't feel in very good shape and
it shows because he is known as a time
travel addict but still going time
trouble every single game is just simply
not going to give you a lot of chances
in a field with so many strong players
that are not going to make huge mistakes
he hasn't won a single game but he
hasn't lost a single game and I think
this is a pretty much a trademark and of
his tournament so far the fact that he's
not losing he's not getting punished and
this one was one of those moments MVL
was white he played a very good game and
at this point he had a golden
opportunity he played a move Bishop to a
three-c v e6 lured by the prospect of
penetrating with a rook on the seventh
rank and recapturing the pawn the
sacrifice material Bishop takes e5
Knight takes five or sixty five F takes
d5 rook takes c7 King the six room takes
d5 sorry F takes G five root x t7 King
the six rook takes e4 the problem is now
with the a pawn supported by the look
behind the pond it's just going to give
me as black enough counter chances to
equalize the position and we've seen
that happening Greece Chuck was once
again let off the hook and I feel this
is something that's been happening in
this tournament we've seen it in the
game against Fabiano Caruana as well he
needs to stop going into time trouble
he's going to allow himself to have much
more chances if he manages to avoid that
last but not least I'm talking about the
wild card
Alexei anko who of course is not in
great shape he's on - - and he's
struggling a little bit in this event
but he had a golden opportunity against
dr napalm yashi and if that would have
one different way I'm sure his
tournament would have been completely
different I'm talking about the moment
when black yana Ponyo she played the
move g6 and at this point i simply do
not understand how he was able not to
play Bishop g6 Bishop g6 if you take I'm
going to simply take on e6 and the fact
that my Queen enters your position is
just going to be deadly unfortunately
for him after g6 he didn't see the move
Bishop to g6 he played the move h5 and
slowly slowly the position petered in to
a draw I feel his simply not finding his
form maybe he's a slowly slowly going to
get back into it but for the moment it
seems like he's a level behind all the
other players and that was it with the
counts corner and the key candid moments